night so much for unity top agenda as
the senator mentioned their item is
congress is now
the latest impeachment charade shift
show against donald trump
and of course this sham trial and the
senate is dead in the water for three
reasons number one
it is completely unlawful as senator
rubio said and unconstitutional
as alan dershowitz has articulately laid
out and so many others
it is unconstitutional to try a
president who is no longer
in office donald trump is a private
citizen the senate
lacks jurisdiction let's start there
jonathan turley
who by the way is not a conservative no
fan of president trump
he said this snap impeachment could
damage the constitution
and will set a terrible precedent the
second reason this impeachment charade
will fail is because the so-called
incitement claims in the article are
bogus
we now have multiple reports even coming
out of the fake news media mob
washington post fake news cnn court
documents now confirming
certain individuals in fact were aligned
and planning their attacks well before
january the 6th like you know planting
pipe bombs the night before in other
words
they were not incited by any remarks of
anybody on january 6
of the president the third reason is
impeachment
and this is a sham is obvious if the
president can be impeached
and convicted for encouraging his
supporters that day
many of you will peacefully
patriotically march to the capitol
to make your voices heard well what
about
this if that's the standard we got a
hell of a lot of impeachment days ahead
of us a lot of trials ahead
take a look they're not going to let up
and they should not
there needs to be unrest in the streets
for as long as there is unrest in our
lives
if you see anybody from that cabinet in
a restaurant
in a department store at a gasoline
station
you get out and you create a crowd when
they go low
we kick them i just don't even know why
there aren't uprisings
all over the country and maybe there
will be i'll put mr burgess up against
uh
sean hannity he'll tear him up
the press always asked me don't i wish i
were debating him
no i wish you were in high school i
could take him behind the gym
that's what i wish i want to tell you
gorsuch
i want to tell you kavanaugh you have
released the whirlwind
and you will pay the price
you will pay the price we didn't play my
favorite maxine waters going
i'm gonna take donald trump out tonight
wow sounds like insurrection talk and
then of course uh you have former
president obama now that you can impeach
former presidents
what about his statement they bring a
knife to a fight
we bring a gun hmm what about the other
violent rhetoric from maxine waters what
about joe biden
going to take of the president trump
behind the gym and beat the hell out of
them
i seem so tough out there i gotta get my
elbows ready in case
you know these liberals come after us
anyway here with more is president
trump's
impeachment defense attorney david shone
david thank you for being with us
i see these three things i see
constitution
and with that what whether or not you
have jurisdiction
um i see that if they're gonna say that
was incitement i don't know
how one peacefully patriotically marches
to the capitol
to do that and we now know from law
enforcement
even from news outlets and even from
court documents that this was all
pre-planned ahead of time
hardly an incitement yeah um
listen you've hit many of the main
arguments that i think are attractive
the american people
they're all right on but i'm going to
say to you that besides the fact that
this process is completely
unconstitutional
and that this is a very very dangerous
road to take with respect to the first
amendment putting it
risk any uh passionate political speaker
uh which is um really and against
everything we believe in in this country
foundation of the first amendment but
i'm going to tell you i think it's also
the most ill-advised
legislative action that i've seen in my
lifetime it is
tearing the country apart at a time when
we don't need anything like that
i think president biden missed a great
opportunity to be a statesman
and demanded that this thing be called
off frankly
this is the political weaponization of
the impeachment process
there was a rush to judgment listen when
president trump became president the day
he was elected
there were calls for his impeachment
ready this is the weapon they've tried
to use against him
but now we know also that the agenda
mrs pelosi and others is simply to bar
president trump from ever running for
president again
and that's about as undemocratic as you
can get can you imagine the slap in the
face that is
to the 75 million or more voters
who voted for donald trump and other
supporters even people who didn't vote
for him
support an open political process
fair-minded people don't support using
the impeachment process
to then try to bar someone from running
for off from running for office again
but you're right also there are many
constitutional arguments against this we
don't use our political preferences
to tear down the constitution after you
make
the constitutional arguments and i know
i've known you for many years you've
been in this business for a long time
uh after you point out that what law
enforcement and court documents say that
it was pre-planned so it wasn't a
spontaneous
it was something that had been planned
ahead of time couldn't have been incited
by anybody if the democrats want to go
down this road of witnesses and i hope
they do
because i think the next logical step i
think we've got to apply the same
standard to schumer
joe biden kamala harris made her remarks
you better beware you better take note
they're not going to stop they won't
stop
this is after they burned down the
minneapolis police station and she was
out about that time
raising money for bail for people
arrested
i think we should apply the same
standards to maxine waters nancy pelosi
chuck schumer joe biden kamala harris
and let the american people compare the
words of all of them
with the president saying you will
peacefully
uh you know march to the capitol so your
voices can get heard
and they take you right yeah go ahead
yeah there are two points about this
i would say you also should be able to
call then many of the senators as
witnesses
because of the awful bias and
prejudgment they've shown
can you imagine any american citizen
considering it to be a
trial in which the judge and jury
has already announced publicly that the
uh defendant must be convicted
in this case and in fact um senator
leahy called
demanded that senator mcconnell vote for
conviction also
um you know both sides everyone it's
clear to them donald trump undercut
undercut democracy how can we possibly
have a fair trial
chuck schumer senator schumer promised a
fair and full trial
you can't when you know that the juror
and the judge are biased going in
the second thing is does this country
really need to see videotapes we know
now apparently
that mr swalwell and the other managers
tend to show videotapes of the riots and
people calling in
people being hurt police officers
talking why does the country need that
now
we would stipulate that there was a riot
that went on that day it was a tragedy
president trump has condemned violence
at all times
read the words of his speech calls for
peacefulness
this has nothing to do with president
trump and the country doesn't need to
just watch videos
of riots and unrest we need to heal now
we need to move forward
joe biden has a platform let's move
forward with it if that's the case
okay if they go there i say you should
go there we'll see what happens david
shone good luck uh we'll be watching a
week from
this week anyway coming up